[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Liana gelareh and this is
your preview episode of Sweetwater
secrets for Episode two eleven chapter
24 the wrestler not now today I'll be
gifting you with an exclusive interview
with KJ Appa and basically all you need
to know is he continues to be the most
endearing person on the planet but
before we get to that I want to
highlight some of your comments about
Riverdale's midseason premiere chapter
23 the Blackboard Jungle now you all
felt very strongly about the last
episode and about my wild [ __ ] theory
and I loved hearing what you had to say
so let's take a look all right guys
Jackie Lopez wrote is it just me that
doesn't believe that the FBI guy is
probably not an FBI guy he's too shady
I agree Jackie there seems to be
something that is really off about an
FBI agent who's blackmailing a teenager
for help what if he's actually working
for hiram lodge police are always a
solution sometimes we need to take
matters into our own hands as for this
episode's most romantic moments poison
apple commented hisses - the fact that
they gave us the barchi kiss then did
nothing about it in the next episode and
kisses - Lian coming back and still
doing Sweetwater secrets oh girl I
wouldn't miss it for the world now
Brooke saloon said hisses - Veronica for
getting over the fact that her best
friend and boyfriend kissed so quickly
like good on her for taking the high
road but I wanted there to be way more
drama now I agree and I see where you're
coming from
but Jenny love added am i the only one
who thinks that Veronica only got
together with Archie because they need
him for the lodge business don't get me
wrong I love Archie she adds and she
also add she like sweet water secrets
but very interesting theory there girl I
don't know about that one do you really
think you're going to help maneuver me
as for my theory that chick is actually
Alice Cooper and f.p Jones's kid well
dozens of you agreed with me and thinks
that chick is definitely a phallus
lovechild
Izzy perk wrote yes I had that series
since last season Dallas will rise and
mädchen and skeet also have such great
chemistry
and so flea em tweeted me definitely
agree with and would totally be down for
your theory to become a reality but if
it gets in the way of hashtag bug head
there would be a serious crisis now on a
similar note Jazmin Jones commented I
don't we check to be related F because
that means that bug head won't happen
because it would be weird now just a
reminder guys even if chick is F P and
Alice's son that doesn't mean that Betty
and Jughead would be related they would
just share sibling which yes is pretty
bizarre now a lot of you are already
trying to connect chick with the black
hood but pure wedding fish was quick to
squash those theories writing okay guys
chick cannot be the black hood remember
when the black hood told Betty that she
would recognize him if he took off his
mask now at that time she had never met
chicks so she wouldn't have recognized
him she just met him for the first time
in the most recent episode also it's
never the person you most suspect very
true but Lauren Linden had her own quote
super weird and twisted theory about
chicks saying I think he's behind the
black hood calling the shots
I think the chick blackmailed Hal which
would somehow explain irritable how and
that how was the black hood that shot
Fred Andrews house it's the profile of
the man we've seen in that episode
interesting theory
Lauren I think you're onto something
there but let's move on alright guys now
it's been a while since we had our last
burgers and lies Fast Five and I thought
you don't like to see KJ oppas adorable
answers take a look we are going to play
a little game that I like to call the
burgers and lives Fast Five I'm gonna
give you five questions I know you love
this game I'm gonna give you five
questions you're gonna answer them as
quickly as possible you ready yes you're
in a diner what is your go-to order but
I don't know check whoa peanut butter in
it as well
no just banana just been in it
interesting alright which couple on the
show are you currently shipping afraid
in Ellis really unexpected which of your
cast mates would you trust with the
secret which my cotton I swear I trust
me trust me
look if I'm saying like who would I
really trust and say look look easy
I tell us the secret about one of the
Riverdale sets I go and sleep in
Archie's bed every once in a while
yeah and I'm eventually I'm gonna stay
there night at the studio I'm not tell
anyone and just wake up so I don't have
to go even working long hours yeah I
mean that's the thing like I'd love to
actually just make myself at home
it's a comfy baby's bedroom in real life
are you a vixen a serpent or pussycat
and why a vixen a servant or a pussycat
Monica pussycat I don't know why I'm not
a difference if an I think I'm like
Manor we have a segment on Sweetwater
secrets called hisses and kisses where's
our favorite moments in the night and
our least favorite moments of the night
and I go no it's not happening
hey I got this Aurora to Scott yeah oh
just the sweetest
all right river babes now that does it
for this preview episode of Sweetwater
secrets but check back with me after you
watch chapter 24 The Wrestler
for my long list of hisses for the
episode spoiler alert
I only had one kiss not my favorite
episode but hit the comments right now
and tell me if you think that chick
Cooper is somehow connected to the black
hood and as always please give this
video a like and subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel so you never miss an
episode of me ranting and raving about
Riverdale bye bye vixens
[Music]
you